it's time now for CBS deals and this
morning we have products that might make
your day a little brighter and easier
and all an exclusive low prices to start
shopping now scan that QR code on your
screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with more good morning
good morning I love all of these
products hit very close to home so I'm
excited to share them with you
cbsdeals.com starting with this Ola
smart security camera now you do have to
connect it and fasten it to wherever and
not break it no so this is excellent I
recently got rid of my security system
because it went off in the middle of the
night and for a week I didn't know if
someone tried to break into my house or
if it was a glitch in the system
thankfully it was a glitch in the system
but with Ola you would know immediately
what was going on because you could see
you can talk to it it can detect people
it could detect animals cars it detects
if someone Falls if someone cries talk
to it like Siri hey are the kids home
from school this is a game changer and
wow is incredible 139.99 30 off for this
say goodbye to the old security systems
this is the only one you need oh my
goodness
does everything my baby monitor made me
think my house was haunted because it's
saying motion and nothing's there so
none of that with Ola ola's got to cover
AI technology okay natural patch told
you before I'll tell you again I am
always the one getting bit when we are
going outside no longer thanks to
Natural patch these are adorable
stickers so you put them on your
clothing I went to a picnic last night
you put it closest to your skin so I put
it on my sleeve I had short sleeves on I
had shorts on I put it on my pant legs
one on each arm one on each leg
essential oils all natural Jeff's coming
in because
I know my daughter they are adorable for
22.95
essential oils it's going to keep those
bubbles away because of the smell 20 off
it comes in a pack of 60. now if you do
get bit they also have itch relief
patches that you put directly on your
skin I hate putting chemicals on my body
I don't do it anymore so this is the
answer wow I love these and I'm none of
we were outside it was gross last night
hot muggy no one got outfit we all had
them on okay we've talked about better
not younger before this hair Serum is
incredible it is designed for women with
thinning hair so if you have thinning
hair you just want to get ahead of it it
starts at the root you put the serum in
the little comb you massage your head it
feels like an at-home spa treatment that
can directly just put you can you can
but then if you because some of them
come with the comb some do not go to
cbsdeals.com see what bundle works best
for you this one's great if you have
already a Sensitive Scalp something for
everybody but I'm telling you this is a
great way to ensure thickness in your
hair or if you know anybody who's like
look I just want a little bit of a boost
try better not younger 28 is what the
deals start at up to 50 percent off it's
relief too yes totally okay now this is
Ion skincare I am always looking for
something new in the skin care
department but with with a lot of these
serums and creams you're like why why am
I putting this on my skin this is
because says with excess iron on the
skin it's going to create Fine Lines
wrinkles discoloration dullness all the
things we don't want this is going to
remove the excess iron and feel it it's
immediately like super hydrating on your
skin you could use this day and night
they also come this little travel kit so
if you're on the go they make face wash
they make all these different products
but give this one a try the price is
insane starting at 54.99 up to 52
percent off today I am telling you it's
created for women 40 and older I'm not
quite there yet but I have a toddler who
doesn't sleep so I need to combat all of
the fine lines because prevention's
coming at me
prevention yes all right Ashley thank
you of course always and of course we
partner with all of these companies to
get these deals to buy anything you saw
today scan that QR code on your screen
or head on over to cbsdeals.com